let's say you're a cheese producer and
you need a loan because you want to buy
a tractor or food for your cows or
clearly just about anything there's a
bank in Italy that will take your cheese
and give you cash this is the story of
three men and millions of dollars worth
of cheese meat mouse song be the cheese
producer in the emiliano region of Italy
he produces parmigiano-reggiano
so-called king of cheese Faria produce
responsible may be for message or no
parasitology iske raise me up or nella
3,000 wheels holy calots a lot of cheese
when Maldor or another cheese producer
in this part of Italy needs a loan they
go to create Emiliano a big Italian bank
and like any bank clicked Emiliano needs
collateral to the low cozy year lasagna
for matzo and to do that he talks to
Fausto cow he works for credit Emiliano
Simona Bank at our vision our SMS Khanna
bank at Kiva a sustained oh they
purgatory the parmigiano Reggiano
parmigiano Reggiano the special kind of
cheese because it needs to be aged for
18 to 36 months and will can be worth
thousands of dollars
make me the safe long-term investment
for the bank the incision is a
Philadelphia Misano Reggiano pero esto
tipo de programa de guarantee is
semplice meant a Dogu tall fast ok quest
el producto traditional meant a steep
eco pair no dns tempo horse a quasi una
Cody questo territorio to be clear the
bank doesn't store the valuable cheese
in its vaults next to gold bars and
stacks of cash they have a special
cheese warehouse down the road fills
with thousands and thousands of wheels
of cheese that's where Roberto Clemente
is the general director of the tagliata
general warehouses that's where
predictor emiliano stores their G which
Apprendi amakura be informal Topher
canto de NT Roberto le Cygne check you
have more than 300,000 meals of cheese
it's currently worth more than 160
million euros the proper care system is
Vario titanium ole invest in Enzo de las
tiendas product reach a windy
Vala Mustafina Labonte well Roberto
sounds to me like the cow the bank
energies are in good hands
[Music]